este domingo el Papa Francisco dedicó
una parte importante de su bendición
Urbi e Urbi a la guerra en Ucrania un
conflicto que definió como una guerra
insensata Francisco deploró la dramática
situación de los millones de ucranianos
que viven esta Navidad en la oscuridad a
la intemperie O lejos de sus hogares a
causa de la destrucción ocasionada por
diez meses de guerra hizo un llamado a
quienes tienen el poder de acallar las
armas y poner fin inmediatamente a esta
guerra también lamentó la situación en
Siria todavía martirizada por un
conflicto que pasó a segundo plano dijo
Francisco pero que no ha acabado todavía
exhortó israelíes y palestinos a la
reconciliación que se retoma el diálogo
dijo Francisco y la búsqueda de
confianza recíproca para poner fin a
décadas de violencia invocó la
convivencia pacífica entre pueblos de la
región del sael perturbada por
enfrentamientos y violencia invocó la
paz en yemen en myanmar en Irán
Francisco tuvo también palabras de
Consuelo hacia las personas más
vulnerables que sufren las consecuencias
de los conflictos en el mundo los
migrantes y refugiados en los niños los
marginados y los ancianos decenas de
miles de personas asistieron a esta
bendición aquí en la plaza de San Pedro
en el Vaticano